ich bin auch kanzler der ungeimpften
besser bundeskanzler olaf scholz im
großen bild am sonntag interview gesagt
heißt er ist auch kanzler von bürgern
die wm entgegen die korona maßnahmen und
eine mögliche impfpflicht protestieren
dies hier sind bilder aus der
vergangenheit nach den blauen in sachsen
aber auch an mehreren anderen orten ist
das leider landesweit geschehen am
dramatischsten war die lage im
thüringischen greiz dort mischten auch
rechtsextreme bei den demonstrationen
mit sie ließen ihrer wut freien lauf 14
polizisten wurden dabei verletzt
es findet eine deutliche radikalisierung
stadt und darüber wollen wir jetzt mit
bild politik chef jan schäfer bei uns im
studio sprechen ja demos gegen die
korona maßnahmen gab es ja schon länger
warum plötzlich diese radikalisierung
also prinzipiell muss man einmal sagen
demonstrationen sind ja überhaupt erst
mal unproblematisch und es ist gut dass
in diesem land demonstriert werden kann
aber der punkt ist immer glaube ich die
rote linie und die darf nicht
überschritten werden die rote linie wird
dann überschritten wenn es zur
radikalisierung kommen wenn es zu gewalt
aufrufen kommt wenn es zu gewalt kommt
und wenn es wie wir ja auch gesehen
haben sogar zu androhungen
möglicherweise auch weiterer straftaten
bis hin zu mord aufrufen oder totschlag
kommt so und genau diese rote linie das
ist das was wir sehen die wird halt
immer öfter jetzt überschritten woher
kommt diese radikalisierung diese
gruppen die stacheln sich gegenseitig
auf unter anderem in sozialen netzwerken
wie telegramm da gibt es so gut wie
keine einschränkungen so gut wie
niemanden der auch mal dazwischen geht
ja auch dinge löscht wenn beispielsweise
es zum mord aufrufen kommt und genau
hier besteht dann so etwas wie eine sich
selbst beschleunigen der echo kammer da
ruft jemand auf und sagt das wäre doch
ein gutes opfer person xy da sagt der
nächste finde ich auch finde ich auch
wenn ich auf und plötzlich gibt es eine
kleine gruppe die der meinung ist sie
ist irgendwie in der mehrheit und
beschleunigt sich in ihrer radikalität
und das ist die große gefahr die wir
hier auch in diesen gruppen bei diesen
demonstrationen sehen ja wir wollen mal
schauen was da ganz genau geschrieben
wird auf dieser plattform telegramm und
hier ist der beitrag hat
möge kretzschmar und seine war sein samt
seinen spitzen in diesem chat jämmerlich
zugrunde gehen dann erfüllt sich
vielleicht mein weihnachtswunsch ihm
auch sein grab zu küssen dieser typ ist
doch sowas von irre mit worten ist das
verbrecher schweinen nicht zu stoppen
kretschmann muss hängen null toleranz
mit diesem despot das schwein
kretschmann muss egal wie zum fall
gebracht werden es reicht jetzt sollte
es an der zeit seinen dem traub die
stirn zu bieten so nicht wie auch immer
man es macht er muss den druck spüren es
gibt keine hilfen für diese desaströsen
und inkompetenten regierungs fritzen ab
an den galgen mit den denkt immer dran
sie haben uns den krieg erklärt
das also äußerungen die sich gegen
sachsens ministerpräsident michael
kretschmer richten eine absolute
hemmungslosigkeit ist entstanden völlig
inakzeptabel und hier müssen alle
sicherheitsbehörden nicht nur die
polizei war alles was auch in sachen
landeskriminalamt gibt der
verfassungsschutz natürlicheren und
müssen diejenigen
festnehmen und dingfest machen die hier
solche aufrufe und solche hetze
verbreiten das ist nicht mehr zu
tolerieren das ist eingangs ja auch
gesagt das sind nicht nur querdenker
oder rechtsradikale die sich da auch
positionieren was kann man denn tun wenn
man einfach mit diesem ganzen corona
maßnahmen vielleicht nicht so der chor
ist und trotzdem eine stimme haben will
und auch gehört werden möchte mehr gut
zu demonstrieren ist ja im prinzip kein
problem es wird jetzt des öfteren
kritisiert dass sich die demonstrieren
die friedlich demonstrieren nicht
abgrenzen von denen die jetzt wirklich
hass und hetze sehen die sogar zur
gewalt aufrufen und sogar gewalttätig
werden also hier muss es zum einen einen
klaren zu geben und du sprichst eine
problematik an die wir sehen die ard
liegt derzeit bei rund zehn prozent kann
zumindest noch nicht so richtig
profitieren von dem rechten
rechtsextremen spektrum was sich da auf
diesen gewalt demonstrationen zum teil
auch jetzt schon gesammelt hat aber was
ist eigentlich wenn ich gegen die
impfpflicht bin und mich aber als ganz
normaler demokrat in einem
demokratischen spektrum befinde dann
habe ich wenn ich in den bundestag
schaue schon ein problem es gibt eine
partei ganz rechts aus dass die fdp ist
gegen die impfpflicht und dann gibt es
einige abgeordnete bei cdu/csu und bei
der fdp sind auch dagegen aber dass der
partei ist dafür und wir kommen da in
ein problem du sprichst es folglich an
was kann ich tun als bürger ich kann
nicht viel tun ich darf bloß nicht in
die extremen komme ich muss einfach
meine meinung immer wieder sagen die
muss sich kundtun auch auf
demonstrationen gehen aber dann gehen
wenn diese demonstration kippen und
radikal werden und zu hass und hetze
aufrufen unser reporter simon natura hat
sich mal in münchen auf der straße
umgehört was die menschen dazu sagen ob
sie auch angst vor dieser
radikalisierung haben
verstehen sie die wut oder die angst der
impfgegner ja gut die guten die achse
impfgegner ist nicht für mich
nachvollziehbar weil einfach die impfung
wichtig ist meiner ansicht nach und wir
ohne die impfung nicht so weit werden
wir jetzt schon sind ich wundere mich
sehr darüber dass man mehr angst hat vor
den nebenwirkungen einer impfung das
gibt es zweifellos als vor der
tatsächlichen erkrankungen die auf der
intensivstation enden kann ich verstehen
ja ja ich meine das ist eigentlich
irgendwie an diskriminierung auch wenn
man selbst auch gelb des und ob kämpft
ist nein also ich fast jedes nicht das
ist bisschen dumm für mich und ist
nachvollziehbar weil wir so lässt man
sich nicht impfen haben sie angst vor
einer radikalisierung der kann ich so
nicht abschätzen weil ich bis jetzt noch
keine impfgegner kennengelernt habe die
dieses mal irgendwie radikal bahn
eingerichtet hat glaube ich nicht ich
habe sie erlebt hier an der münchner
freiheit da haben sie so kleine zettel
ausgehend an der wäscheleine mit was für
alles furchtbare dinge passiert sind und
wer uns alles belegt also ich finde die
gruselig wenn ich diese diese demos
mache ein bisschen aggressiv sind aber
sonst radikalisierung denke ich nicht
weil er mehr teil würde ich sagen doch
eher vernünftiger ins um sich impfen
lassen wollen würde es hat keinen sinn
die sind einfach betoniert tut mir leid
dazu geschaltet ist uns peter neumann
eine sicherheits experte vom king's
college in london
zugeschaltet ist uns der
sicherheitsexperte peter neumann vom
king's college in london
hallo herr neumann guten morgen herr
normalen wer sind diese menschen die
dort zunehmend protestieren
es kommt drauf an wir haben eine
ziemlich große bewegung überall in
deutschland die sehr
unkonsolidiert daraufhin
unterschiedliche leute mit in teilen
deutschlands in sachsen thüringen wird
die bewegung ganz klar von
rechtsextremisten dominiert die sind
dort vorherrschen in anderen teilen
deutschlands sind sie die minderheit
also in nordrhein-westfalen zum beispiel
höre ich aus sicherheitskreisen da wird
geschätzt ungefähren und 15% der
mitlaufenden sind rechtsextreme und das
ist auch interessant weil bei dieser
bewegung viele leuten das haben studien
gezeigt viele leute mit der wahl sind
die sich politisch noch nicht engagiert
haben also es wird erika anthroposophen
homöopathen das wird sich alles noch im
laufe der zeit
konsolidieren es erinnert ja so ein
bisschen auch an diese päda bewegung wo
aus einem konkreten anliegen damals ging
es um islamismus dann sozusagen ein
sammelbecken der unzufriedenen wird dass
man gar nicht mehr klar definieren kann
ist das ähnlich es
ist insofern ähnlicher ist dass die
leute natürlich auf die straße gehen und
als dass diese bewegungen relativ
plötzlich entstanden ist was der
unterschied ist glaube ich ist dass ich
in den letzten wochen und monaten schon
ziemlich dramatische radikalisierung hin
zur gewalt ergeben hat das war bei p&g
da nicht unbedingt der fall was wir eben
in den letzten wochen und monaten bei
dieser kroner leutner bewegungen sehen
das sind leute die ganz konkrete
widerstands native formulieren die sagen
wir brauchen jetzt der rechtfertigung
dafür müssen uns was zurecht legen dass
es uns erlaubt auch gewalt zu ergreifen
und das haben wir bei peter so extrem
und so schnell nicht gesehen wie
gefährlich ist diese radikalisierung
geht das bis hin zu terror ich glaube
schon ich denke auch dass wir
innerhalb der nächsten monate eine
systematischere gewalt bewegung aus
dieser bewegung heraus sehen
was wird bereits jetzt sehen ist
natürlich schon gewalt wir haben
angriffe auf journalisten der angriffe
auf polizisten wir haben den vorfall in
idar oberstein wo ein beschäftigter in
einem geschäft der gebeten hat die maske
aufzusetzen erschossen würde das haben
wir schon was wir noch nicht haben ist
so die systematischere langfristigere
gewalt aber ich glaube ihr kleiner die
bewegung wird desto mehr radikalisiert
sie sich und was wir möglicherweise
jetzt schon sehen ist das herauskommen
von strukturen kleineren strukturen die
einen eben auch systematisch stimmte
ziele angreifen bauen können wir von
einer spaltung der gesellschaft
tatsächlich reden oder ist das wirklich
eine minderheit die dort radikalisiert
auftritt und der großteil der
bevölkerung ist eben nicht davon
betroffen klar also die der großteil der
bevölkerung ist natürlich nicht davon
betroffen
und insofern ist es keine spaltung die
jetzt 50 50 ist es ist schon eine
spaltung insofern dass es eine
signifikante minderheit ist also selbst
wenn wir von zehn prozent der
bevölkerung sprechen dann sind es in
deutschland acht millionen menschen und
gerade wenn es um das thema terrorismus
oder gewalt geht da brauchen sie nicht
unbedingt viele leute dafür und wenn man
da eine basis hat von was weiß ich
einigen hunderttausenden und das sehen
wir ja in den sozialen medien das
durchaus einige hundert tausenden dieser
bewegung folgen dann ist das genug um
für die gesellschaft jedem ort jede
menge probleme zu produzieren stichwort
soziale medien die radikalisierung
beginnt ja dort schon insbesondere auf
dem nachrichtendienst telegramm müsste
die politik da einschreiten
beispielsweise diesen messenger dienst
verbieten
also ich glaube dass wir schon ganz
hilfreich wenn die politik bei telegramm
machen würde was sie zb facebook macht
oder bei twitter macht dass sie ebenso
zu sagen versucht die gesetze
durchzusetzen denn die gelten momentan
auf telegramm nicht das problem mit
telegramm ist telegramm ist anders als
facebook oder twitter ein sehr
mysteriöser service also man weiß gar
nicht genau wo die beheimatet sind was
das geschäftsmodell ist wo die überhaupt
setzen und das ist der unterschied wenn
man wie facebook oder twitter wollen
auch in deutschland geld verdienen
deswegen sind sie das sind sie deswegen
sind sie belangbar bei telegramm ist es
etwas schwierig also ich bin mal
gespannt darauf wie die deutsche justiz
oder wie die deutsche politik versucht
sich ein telegramm handhabbar zu werden